This ancient message took centuries to crack.
We could always read this message.
We still have no clue how to read this message. Why
[inaudible]?
What if history were hiding something from you? Would you want to know about it?
Well, if you stick with me a few minutes,
we'll start getting you to think like a decipher.
Then you can join the club and hold a flickering lab of to an old wall and with
your perceptive gaze, not slowly and enlightened appreciation of the symbols.
I'll bring the symbols and techniques you're buying the hat and the lamp though.
If you stay for this series, we'll tell tales and decipher it.
That take us from the sands of Egypt through the Central American jungle to the
middle of the Pacific.
You'll work alongside history's great decoders and some crackpots in their
relentless attempts to recover voices long vanished.
We already saw with decipherment is not like cryptography or crypt analysis,
but what is it? Yes,
like decipherment is something we do with a message we can read.
That was a bit vague. Let's go again.
Decipherment is an operation performed on an unknown message and it requires two
components. First, a script, oh writing system.
These visual etched, inked, carved,
whatever symbols that were eager to read mocking us silently across the ages are
called glyphs.
The meaningful units we're trying to identify among these glyphs are called
graphemes. The other thing we need is a language.
If there's no language underlying the symbols at all,
there's no linguistic message to decipher some claim.
This is true of the indice scripts or the tartare via tablets.
Before this video,
you talked about decipherment the way people normally do discipling symbols to
dig up the hidden ancient message inside of them.
We built on that by admitting that we have to identify the messages writing
system and its language to unearth its meaning.
That's our first understanding of decipherment. Let's call it model one,
but if you're joining our secret club,
you have to change the way you look at decipherment.
Decipherment buying certain language bits to certain writing bits and sees if
they coordinate,
if the message reads naturally with that writing system and that language model
number one, I really don't like these names. Let's see.
This one has layers are kind of hidden guts,
and this one is matching pieces.
Hidden guts is more romantic, more or regular,
but what happens when some hack decipher comes along and challenges you're
reading hidden guts tells you to appear through the gruffy.
Mckay's like a kind of sear sage matching pieces invites you to compare texts
and find a best fit.
It even invites predictions when we find texts and more texts in the language.
It's a fresh starting point for thinking about how to decipher,
but what can you decipher? What can you decipher?
That's actually a great question for next time.
[inaudible].